[Music]
okay Jun you're all prepped up for your
weight loss surgery doctor phase will be
here any minute
after the weight loss surgery I'm really
completely different I don't want you to
look different I think I'm about to cry
let's get to well I know that Wade
Keller worried about me not good I kind
of have something safe but I really
don't want it I'm hungry
uh I got you doc you could possibly
bleed out but you know they all right
okay joy let's get you ready for surgery
oh stop the frame y'all probably
wondering how me mama June got right
here Jana me and my family from the pop
culture of an omen on here comes honey
boo boo
you know honey boo boo bop honey boo boo
box 11 years of drama where the lawn is
dad was getting way too much so I gave
him one last chance and drag shoe burrs
ass to marriage boot camp
mama G needs to get closure while I was
there the truth came out know how you
were saying I have cheated I have
The Bachelor was cheating on me but the
truth can also set you free Rhyno first
I kicked sugars ass to the curb then I
got a whole new curve I used the last of
my savings it bought me pumpkin Alana a
brand new home in my hometown goodbye
old life goodbye means that don't treat
me right your body this old body when
I'm done I'm not even gonna recognize my
own stuff in the mirror y'all better get
ready amazing don't miss the new series
mama June but not too hot Friday
February 24th at 10:00 only on WE tv
[Music]
you